[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes i'm cindy you the spectators
broadcast editor bringing the show to
you on thursday 14th of july
on the show this week
tory mps are fighting for the keys to
number 10. who's winning i'll speak to
james forsyth and katie balls
former cabinet minister liam fox is back
in the front runner rishi sinak he joins
the show to tell us why
after calling saudi arabia a pariah joe
biden is meeting crown prince mohammed
bin salman to ask him to pump more oil
will mbs do it paul wood and mary kissel
will be on the show
and finally is it inevitable that humans
will leave earth and start life among
the stars i'll speak to the astronomer
martin reese
a spectator subscription is now better
value than ever before as a new
subscriber joining today you'll pay just
one pound a week for unlimited online
and app access in your first year
to subscribe go to spectator dot co dot
e k forward slash tv offer
and why not subscribe to our youtube
channel click the red subscribe button
at the bottom of this video and tap the
bell icon to make sure you never miss an
episode
it's only been a week since the prime
minister resigned and the tory
leadership contest has already turned
into blue murder as fraser nelson writes
in this week's cover article it's a
fast-moving story but here to give us
the latest i'm joined by political
editor james forsyth and our deputy
political editor katie balls
katie and james thanks so much for
joining spectator tv now we're recording
this on thursday morning um casey what
is the situation like at the moment
so i can say what the situation is but
of course things are moving very fast
when it comes to this tory leadership
contest because we have breakneck speed
parliamentary round and so at the time
of speaking we've uh had the first
ballot we have the second ballot later
today but i think if you take a step
back uh effectively
i think rishi sunik is still the front
runner but
actually the person who seems to have
the most momentum behind them is penny
mordant
um when it came to the first ballot you
had a situation where penny warden was
in second place um not that far behind
rishi sunak and now i think there's a
big question as to can she overtake is
this the person to beat because all the
membership polling is suggesting penny
morden would do uh well in any run-up if
she makes the final two beating i think
all the candidates the other candidate
who's uh stoking some excitement is
kevin badenock and therefore you're
starting to see a situation where the
fresh faces those who are less
associated with boris johnson's
government who haven't served in senior
roles in his cabinet seem to be the ones
that are generating the most buzz
amongst membership
and therefore there's a question as to
do rishi sunik and there's trust who's
still seen as two serious contenders for
the final two do they start to look too
establishment could we have a bit of an
upset on our hands when it comes to who
goes to the membership james this is
telling us something about what the
membership wants in that they want
something fresh from not associated with
the conservative government under boris
johnson penny bourdain and kenny bailey
were both junior ministers rather than
cabinet ministers as liz trust and rishi
sunac have been and we've seen polls
this week that show that actually as
katie says kemi and penny would do much
better with the members than liz or
rishi
so i think the fundamental tory problem
is that in 2019
they won this big majority on the base
of basically two things getting brexit
done and beating jeremy corbyn and both
of those were achieved by the result
itself almost uh and since then the
prospectus has been very uncertain it's
not be and in some ways kovid disguised
that because for two years as almost the
government was firefighting but now
we've come out of cobid uh and it the
need for a new agenda is is all the more
pressing because you've got to get the
economy moving you've got to deal with
all these backlogs and public services
and i think that that sense that there
isn't uh a clear agenda at the moment is
why those who didn't hold high office in
this government like penny morgan and
kenny babenov are
are getting the attention that they are
and i think this is this is this is the
the the challenge here and we wait to
see how the rest of this contest panned
out and i think now the question is you
know penny morden this is
has
dramatically uh
moved on up the rankings in this race
and she's now going to come under
scrutiny you've seen and the question is
you know how does she cope with that i
asked one um very wise former tory mp
this morning i said uh what do you think
happens next and they said
it depends how uh the hms modern to say
put it copes with the kind of incoming
that it got from say david frost this
morning
well kitty just just on penny mordent
and we're going into the weekend and
there's going to be a few rounds of tv
debates is that uh the moment to watch
for one some of these relatively unknown
candidates not just penny morden but
also tom toucan had um to make
themselves known to the public known to
the members and is that where they could
be falling as well
yeah it's a big opportunity it's also a
big risk um effectively it's been
interesting looking at the visibility of
the candidates so there was an
interesting polling out which suggested
when it comes to the general public a
really small percentage um would be able
to recognize penny morden if you showed
a photo and say who that was and even
amongst the tory voters i think it's
still below 20
and that suggests that you're in a
situation where um there's lots of buzz
around a person but they could fall
apart quite quickly and you uh james
mentioned the david frost criticism that
is of course that david frost was
suggesting that penny morden was uh you
know not very capable when it came to
negotiating on brexit and he didn't know
where she was most of the time and he
and eventually he actually asked to have
her moved because he found her that
unhelpful so i think the fact that penny
morden's surging ahead does mean you're
going to start to hear more attacks but
as you say i think in those debates the
thing about liz trust and rishi sunak is
while they can obviously increase their
visibility still i think lots of people
already made up their minds about them
they have a perception of who they think
they are and therefore with those
lesser-known candidates so penny morden
kerry badenock and tom teugenhart this
is the chance for them to land an
impression on the nation um but if they
have a bad interview if they don't look
as though they're on top of policy
details they could start to fall quite
quickly as well so i think it's gonna be
quite a high pressure weekend and
particularly something like penny mordon
we haven't seen that much of her she
hasn't done loads of media even in her
campaign video it was largely pictures
of other people some of them didn't want
their picture in it so the video had to
be taken down and amended and she was
only at the very very end speaking so
as you get the candidates out more i
think things could change
james let's talk about that negative
briefing that you both have alluded to
it has been a really really vicious
fight so far do you think this is
extraordinary for a leadership contest
that you've seen um and also why do you
think it's happening like that
so yeah i mean there has been a kind of
demolition derby element of all this and
i think what's quite striking about
the lord frost attack on penny morgan
this morning is how simon clark who's
one of tr liz ross's big um
cabinet backers you know immediately
retweeted a journalist talking about the
the the frost attack there's no attempt
and frost says i think is i think
expected to come out for the trust camp
later today and this obviously follows
days in which you've had nadine doris
and jacob rees-mong trying to take a
baseball bat to rishi sunak um and you
know this is this has i think the
challenge for the tories is you know how
um unpleasant does this get leadership
contests can work one of two ways for a
party either they dominate the news and
that makes it quite hard for anybody
else to get to to to to get any
attention get any traction and politics
can actually do well in the leadership
contest already just looks a party
looking very divided to the voters and i
think at the moment the risk of
victories is that it's on on the latter
stage um of things although someone did
make an interesting observation to me
that when they go to the final two um
sometimes strange things happen between
the final two candidates so for example
in 2005 um no one would have described
david davis and uh david cameron who's
going to bosom buddies when they went
into that final two but touring the
country doing all those events together
they did kind of find a modus for vendor
with each other and so i think there's
you know maybe
maybe if one's been optimistic for the
tourists there's a chance that that
happens between the final two but what
is certainly true
is uh that you can't walk down the
colonnade in parliament without someone
stopping you to say something
disobliging about one of the candidates
katie in his cover article for the
magazine this week um spectator editor
fraser nelson is pretty disparaging
about this kind of negative campaigning
pointing out that none of them have any
positive ideas
what do you make of that is that harmful
the conservative party in the medium
term as james says um and do you think
is it because they're running out of
ideas that they weren't saying anything
positive about themselves
i think all these contests become quite
toxic at some point i think you can say
in this one it's become toxic very
quickly and but that's partly because
there's so much poison in the party
effectively there is still a decent
chunk of mps who don't think boris
johnson should have had to resign
they blame figures such as sergio javid
who's already been knocked out and
pointing out perhaps there is something
and you know he who wheels the knife
doesn't get to wear the crown
and also rishi sunak and i think the
level of venom towards rishi sunak uh by
some johnson loyalists is really adding
to this i think there is definitely a
sense of anyone but rishi among some mps
you can see that in some of the backers
to the liz trust campaign and also the
framing of the liz trust campaign so yes
talking about the economy but also
saying i am the only candidate who can
take on rishi sunak and i think the fact
they think that is a convincing message
shows you um the two criticisms against
russia sunak one of which is he was not
sufficiently supportive of boris johnson
there's a betrayal narrative some
figures nadine doris jacob rees-mogg are
really trying to push and then of course
those who oppose him on fiscal policy
and so i think the nature of how this
leadership contest came about um it
didn't come about because there was an
election defeat and um there is a way
this big battle of ideas now there's
still a battle of ideas going on but it
came about because of personality and
problems with boris johnson
an attempt to force him out and it just
does mean you're in this landscape where
things are pretty febrile and obviously
we use that word a lot in westminster
but i think that is why it can at times
feel you know dark ops blue on blue and
the fact that now you have um you know
can people such as david frost going
after penny morden as well as uh people
that nadine doris going after rishi
sooner it just shows that i think this
is going to get more vicious before it
gets calmer and depending on who is in
the final two it could be a very very
bruising summer for the tory party katie
just on that you interview liz trust for
this week's magazine what did she say
that jumped out at you what were her
ideas um what what did anything surprise
you
well i think ultimately liz trust is one
of several candidates in this leadership
contest who is pledging to cut tax um
and specifically in the case of liz
trust to reverse national insurance and
i think that's something she's
suggesting she would do on day one in
terms of that hike and also looking at
corporation tax and and she is saying
how she will fund that which not all the
candidates have done and that is to
treat covert debt like wartime debt take
a longer time to push back ultimately
she's going for economic growth but the
implication is if needed to she will
borrow to fund tax cuts um so i think
the level of honesty there and actually
not just talking about cutting taxes
lots of people have done but offering a
bit of a uh some flavor how how you're
really going to achieve that is
something her camper hoping will show
that she is more of a serious contender
than some of the others in the sense
that she has experience she would
actually deliver on the things she is
saying when you have figures in the
rishi camp you want to suggest lots of
these things are pie in the sky or
irresponsible i also found it quite
interesting talking to liz trust the
interviews in two stages um
began in france when boris johnson was
still prime minister and then of course
had to be updated given the current
situation um but there was a nickname uh
for liz trust which first aired in the
spectator several years ago of the human
hand grenade now this is alleged to have
come from dominic cummings and he at the
time was with michael gove and the idea
was that wherever she goes things would
blow up so i think at least for some it
was not meant as a compliment right so i
asked liz trust you know how do you feel
about this nickname which these days has
held
at you in an insulting way i think
dominic cummings tweets it um
semi-regularly and and she said it was a
she took it effectively as a back-handed
compliment and it showed that she gets
things done so i thought uh yeah trying
to turn a criticism into an advantage
and feed it back to that delivery line
and james in your political column this
week you write about a fundamental thing
that all of these candidates will have
to prove that they can do which is to
renew the conservative party tell us
about that
yeah so the hardest thing for any
political party to achieve is renewal in
office and the tories have done it twice
um in 2016 they changed leader and tack
in response to changing circumstances
the brexit referendum and in 2019 they
did the same thing albeit more
more successfully um again because of
brexit and i mean both 2016 and 2019 it
was clear that brexit was the thing that
the tory party needed to shift on to win
again i think it is less clear now
what the issue is that the tories need
to shift on to to win again i suspect
ultimately the biggest challenge to get
is to get the economy growing again you
know why is why are the choices so hard
in british politics right now because in
the 30 years before the financial crash
productivity grew over two percent a
year uh in the time since 2008 product
deductivity has grown about north point
uh 0.4 yeah um and that is one of the
things that is making things so hard i
think there is also a big question which
is the the tories have to show
that uh
they can govern competently i mean this
is one of the big
one of the big challenges for whoever um
succeeds boris johnson is to show that
the kind of government is delivering and
getting things done uh and you know that
it has a it has because i think there is
a dangerous narrative taking hold in the
country but this is a country where you
struggle to get a gp appointment where
nhs waiting lists are still going up
they've got to be able to show that they
can that they they can reform public
services so that they deliver for people
and katie just finally and by the time
viewers are watching this another round
of the leadership contest will have
happened one more candidate will be out
taking us down to five but from friday
onwards katie what are we going to be
looking out for what are the key moments
in the contest
so after thursday's round which we'll
have by the time you're watching this
and there'll be a situation
by which there'll be a slight lull over
the weekend in terms of no more ballots
there's not one on friday so it kicks
off again on monday and that means uh
the candidates have uh friday night and
the weekend here for several tv debates
and also to set out their stall ahead of
the knockout rounds next week and we
would expect and the plan is
according to the 22 committee to have
the final two candidates by next week
and and therefore we will know who was
going to the membership and settling
down for a long campaigning summer of
various hustings katie and james thanks
very much now for viewers who want more
up-to-date political analysis maybe even
daily or twice daily we've got a very
regular podcast it's called coffeehouse
shots you can get it for free wherever
you get your podcast from
and it features katie balls james
forsyth fraser nelson and sometimes i'm
on there too talking about the twists
and turns of every single moment of
westminster politics so that's where you
get the daily update from
now let's talk to one of the senior
tories with a horse in the race former
cabinet minister liam fox says that he
is hashtag ready for rishi he joins me
now
liam fox thank you so much for joining
spectator tv
now to start with tell us why you're
back in russia scenario
well i think that mps look at candidates
in two ways um some of them look at them
tactically
who will knock out whom and who might
give me a job others look at them i
think that very directly
i look at candidates and i think
i know what i believe in which is the
candidate closest to what i believe in
in all these elements and you know what
i wanted to see was i wanted to see
somebody who actually believed in brexit
i wanted to see someone who believed in
free markets who believed in free trade
and was definitely
anti-protectionism someone who believes
in the union someone who believes in the
strength of our relationship with the
united states and someone who
understands
aspiration the value of education
and
what it means to create opportunity
prosperity and hope in the country so
rishi was the candidate in my view who
was closest to all of those boxes you
never find a candidate
who is entirely
in line with all the things you think
and always it's about which one is the
closest
from all the things that you've just
said why not lose trust
because uh rishi was a brexiteer
even when he was put under enormous
pressure as a newly elected mp by the
cameron administration you're telling
him that he wouldn't have a future
if he voted for brexit
he was in there in the trenches all the
time and i know that other candidates
have had
a conversion um after the referendum and
it's not i don't in any way um cast
aspersions on the sincerity in that but
i i like to have someone who was there
in the fight at the time
even when it was thought to be going to
be on the losing side
um and stuck by their principles all the
way through for me that is what
leadership is about
and liam is clear that you are a low tax
small state believer in the past you've
called yourself an unreconstructed
free-market thatcherite but this
candidate rishi sooner you know the
former chancellor he has resided over
the highest tax burden in a 75-year
period
and he's just about to increase
corporation tax from 19 to 25
so how can you be so sure that he's also
a fiscal conservative what makes you
think that he's going to bring tax cuts
later down the line well what you
described as being a fiscal conservative
it's not been willing to spend money um
without willing to balance the books and
this idea that you can increase spending
and
cut taxes at the same time results in
only one thing and that's increased
borrowing and borrowing is merely
deferred to taxes if we want taxes to
come down
then we have to earn tax cuts by having
increased prosperity increased growth in
the economy um and control our spending
and i'm convinced that that rishi sunnah
is someone who believes
in a smaller state over time
now
you could argue yes that he was the
chancellor who oversaw the increased
spending in the pandemic but i didn't
hear many other members of the cabinet
at the time saying they were going to
resign and protest likewise
the increased spending on the nhs and
social care about which i have different
reservations
mainly that that money
is not going to social care but into the
nhs and the nhs will cry foul when it
has to hand that money over to social
care that's a different issue
but if we want to see more spending on
the nhs either that money has to be
diverted from other programs within a
contained government spending program or
we generate more income to pay for it or
we tax more of course or we borrow more
which i i rule out so and
you know there's a there's a view now
that you can simply cut tax and and
that's fine it will produce growth
itself
and i'm i've never really
believed in that i think you can cut
business taxes and get increased
business activity
uh but i think that overall
you have a duty to the next generation
not to borrow money
and defer the taxes on to them for our
spending today
so if the state's going to get smaller
under a prime minister sunak what is he
going to be cut and is that a return to
austerity
well i think that there's there's a
debate that we haven't really got into
in this in this uh
election which is you know how is
whitehall shaped how is the overall
government run in the country and also
what i would say i would categorize as
the difference between growth
and wealth creation and by that i mean
that any dummy
can spend tomorrow's money today
borrow it and call the increased level
of activity growth
i think that's very different from
wealth creation by which i mean that
wealth creation is when we take our
unique ip
and we turn that into a good or a
service that doesn't exist today or a
better good or service than exists today
and what's the problem with us at the
present time the problem with us is that
we have too much ip leakage out of the
country at the moment because we have a
real problem with scale ups
we're great at developing the ip we're
great at startups we're very innovative
we're very creative as a nation but
we're very poor at financing it and i
think one of our problems is that to
genuinely create more
wealth and create more prosperity
we need to be thinking much more about
how we remove the supply-side
restrictions
that stop us being able to scale up a
lot more with private equity than we do
today that's a that's a major challenge
and i'm rather disappointed that the
debate has so far been you know you said
this you said that um rather than
setting out what i would like to see as
a very constructive economic program for
the future
and liam your former international trade
secretary um what do you make of the
government's plans to extend steel
terrorists for another two years if
there is a prime minister sunak will you
expect him to be cancelling those
tariffs
well i would hope so i'm appalled by it
you know i spent
three years setting up the department
for international trade based on a
concept of open outward-looking trading
relations for the uk how we would
increase our exports how would increase
both inward and outward investment
we set up the tra
to be able to set the rules as part of
our wto world trade organization
obligations and the current government
passed legislation to be able to
override that which i found very hard to
swallow
but then to actually apply
these protections to the steel industry
and which are in breach uh which the
government acknowledge of our
international obligations uh goes too
far and i said so in my letter to boris
johnson
the danger here is that in order to
protect a small bit of one industry lots
of other industries feel the full force
of retaliatory measures that other
countries are allowed to have so for
example scotch whiskey
ceramics
the bike industry them could all be hit
by
measures that might be taken by
countries like say
south korea
nobody wins in a trade war and why
after we've got brexit we would take
britain back to a more protectionist
position than the eu that we've left i
find really difficult to swallow and
ultimately i couldn't
and liam i also want to get your
thoughts on fraser nelson's cover
article in this week's spectator in
which he talks about the dirty tricks
and the black ops that happen in
leadership contests um one trick is to
lend votes where one candidate
lends votes to another candidate because
they believe that that one will be
weaker in the final face off now some
actually say that this is what happened
to you when you ran for leadership
against david cameron that the cameron
campaign lent votes to david davis's
campaign because they believe that david
davis would be a weaker candidate to go
against than yourself do you think
there's any truth in that i think it
does happen i
find it very sad that it happens um this
is not a game
and and even more than an opposition
we have to take our current task really
seriously
we're electing a prime minister of the
country
in just a few weeks time
they will have to take on all the
responsibilities of prime minister from
nuclear deterrent to our other foreign
policy to our
domestic range of policies from health
care to education they'll have to set up
a cabinet they'll need to understand how
the whole government's going to move
forward two and a half years or less
from an election they'll have to deal
with high inflation
not only in britain but internationally
as well as what i regard as monetary
policy that's been two lakhs in the uk a
whole range of issues
there's no time for learning on the job
this is about getting somebody in place
who can be prime minister quickly who
understands how the system works at the
highest level
and can put a team together and
i when i how this relates to your
question about lending votes
i think that i would judge
the the best candidate to be prime
minister
by
those they attract to them
and we can't have somebody being the
boris candidate or the anti-boris
candidate or the anti-somebody else
candidate what we need to have is an
understanding that in the conservative
party we avoid
external coalitions by maintaining an
internal coalition and what i want to
see is somebody preferably somebody from
the the right of the conservative party
where i regard
rishi as coming from but i also want to
see a broad tent
i want to see as uh incorporating the
talents that we have within a single
government programme if we start to be
naughty single party not a broad church
but a coalition of political minorities
geographical and on different parts of
the political spectrum i think we simply
add uh strength to our opponents so
for me do i have a candidate who
reflects
more closely what i believe who can
bring different parts of the party
together
experienced enough to hit the ground
running and intelligent enough to deal
with the different hurdles that will
face us it's not an easy package to find
and you can never find a perfect one but
for me rishi sunite fix fits that
picture better than anyone else well
just finally liam on that disunity that
you're talking about i have to say that
the last seven days for outside and
probably inside observers of the
leadership contest haven't you know
given us much hope of unity going
forward what do you make of nadine doris
and other boris johnson supporters
claims that rishi's sunax campaign has
been engaging in lending votes to jeremy
hunt's campaign and others well i've not
seen any of that i have to say
and i just i find leadership contests
truly awful it's hard to explain how
poisonous the atmosphere can be
it ruins friendships it damages
relationships in in the long term and i
actually had to send an email to someone
who's a friend of mine the other day and
saying don't lose your friends over this
i've seen it all before it's not worth
it
um but that something comes across
colleagues when they get into these
situations my view would be
pick the candidate who reflects your
views campaign for them and after it's
all over come back together and
recognize that the real danger to
conservatism doesn't come from within
the conservative party it lies out there
from socialism and nationalism to very
toxic forces which will not only
potentially
damage the conservative party
irreversibly but much more importantly
damage our country irreversibly
liam fox thank you so much for joining
spectator tv
remember if you enjoy what we do here at
the spectator you can subscribe to the
magazine and to our online content to
subscribe today go to spectator.com
forward slash tv offer
president biden visits saudi arabia this
week it's an awkward trip for him given
his strong condemnation of prince
mohammed bin salman for the killing of
the journalist jamal khashoggi but given
the russian invasion america needs the
gulf state to pump more oil
that might explain why biden scrummed
when asked about the trip
paul wood writes about this
uncomfortable position in this week's
issue and he joins me now together with
mary kissel former advisor to trump
secretary of state mike pompeo
paul welcome to spectator tv
now in the magazine this week you write
about biden's visit to saudi arabia can
you tell us why this trip is so
important
it's all about the price of oil russia
is funding its war in ukraine with oil
at around 100 a barrel
and the number one priority for the us
and indeed for britain is to undercut
russia with economic sanctions
by turning off the billions of dollars
in hard currency they can get from oil
so they need the opec countries of which
saudi arabia is the most important to
raise oil production
now here's where the embarrassment
factor comes in
saudi arabia is supposed to be a pariah
in the words of joe biden in his
election campaign
18 months ago
but the opec meeting is in saudi arabia
and of course it's the saudi voice which
dominates opec so he has to he has to go
and pay his respects off his cap to mbs
the man who murdered
or ordered the murder
of a dissident journalist jamal
khashoggi in cold blood at least
according to the cia
it doesn't do any harm either that this
would bring down prices at the pumps for
americans five dollars a barrel record
prices for americans
people are feeling economic pain in the
united states the same as everywhere
else
and of course the wider economic
relationship with saudi arabia is
important so
all of which is to say having a
conscience is expensive and now perhaps
is not the time that the us leader
thinks he can afford that
and presumably saudi arabia will be
asking for something in return for
pumping more oil if they acquiesce at
all which poor i guess they might not
but if they do they might be asking for
something in return which is to stop
talking about human rights stop talking
about khashoggi um at all
well on the question of whether they can
actually do anything
emmanuel macron the french president was
caught on camera i thought it was a
private conversation telling president
biden well
don't assume the saudis can actually
give you much more
but i think even a million barrels a day
would be significant people analysts who
study this for a living are talking
about a million barrels a day what do
the saudis want well ultimately they
want security guarantees that's what the
deal has always been for the 75 years
that the us has been in busy in business
with the saudi royal family
and security guarantees at the moment
will take an interesting new form
um there are
these things called the abraham accords
negotiated by jared kushner president
trump's son-in-law
a
a deal a new alliance between israel
and one very important gulf country the
united arab emirates also bahrain
it may not be that the saudis get to
officially officially be part of the
abraham accords but
in orbit name
um there may be an alliance with israel
which would be in underwritten by
american security guarantees uh
potentially expensive new commitments i
think that's probably number one
priority for the saudis but also very
usefully for mbs he's out of the penalty
box um president trump in trump's own
words saved his ass by not immediately
uh pointing the figure at mbs but then
joe biden took a very interesting step
quite early on
um
after he arrived in the oval office of
publishing the cia
assessment which said that mbs was
guilty of organizing this murder it was
one of his very close associates in the
royal court who did it allegedly a man
called saud
now at the time when this was published
there were some sanctions against minor
saudi officials nothing against mbs so
already then there was a recognition
that mbs was not going to pay the price
for this if indeed he's guilty of it
let's remember the saudis deny it but
now this is kind of the the public
affirmation of this
and i think something of a humiliation
for biden he looked very conflicted when
he was speaking about this at the nato
summit stumbling over his words uh more
than might be accounted for if as some
people
losing some mental function that's
always the allegation about biden these
days including on saudi television by
the way a very funny sketch on saudi tv
shows um
kamala
harris literally holding up biden at the
podium
um but for anybody else it's all about
uh publicly he's out of the penalty box
um and the saudis are crowing in a press
release from their embassy in washington
dc about a meeting with a long list of
things to be discussed one-on-one with
biden we'll see if the president has to
swallow that if he has to shake the hand
of the man that allegedly issued the
death warrant for jamal khashoggi
that's incredible what you say about the
saudi um
sketch there so they're they're
essentially expecting something like
this to have happened anyway presumably
because as you say having a conscience
is expensive even when biden was having
his tough words they probably expected
him to come back to them and actually
don't respect him that much
we're talking about relations between
states in terms of personalities
and in one way that's false because
states have interests which go beyond
individual personalities but if the era
of donald trump told us anything it's
that personalities do matter
mbs is is quite a volatile character but
reminiscent of trump in that he's got an
explosive temper apparently he can be
extremely direct
um with visiting foreign leaders and
this is the crucial point uh he's the
crown prince now his father king salman
is is apparently quite ill
and if the succession goes as expected
this could be the ruler of saudi arabia
for the next 50 years this is the man
that people have to do business with and
his personality very volatile matters
here and that's the man that president
biden's dealing with
yeah well what next for biden then paul
do you think he can you know not have a
gaff as he visits saudi arabia this week
not say something accidentally that you
know accuses um mbs of some kind of
moral flaw um i mean is he actually
going to be able to off the cap
well this is all about um the mental
capacity of president biden now on the
one hand
this is a president who is immensely
experienced in foreign affairs he was
vice president had some very important
brief
as vice president including
afghanistan
and before that let's not forget as a
senator he was chairman of the senate
foreign affairs committee often it
seemed in that role as if he knew more
than some of the witnesses who appeared
before that committee so this is a man
who again in contrast to his predecessor
knows what he is talking about and knows
how to deal with foreign leaders
but um
apparently well-sourced stories uh in
the u.s media for instance say that
his aides are quite worried about
over-taxing him he is alleged to work
only a five-day week and they try to
ring fence the weekend so that he is not
over-taxed so that he has not pushed too
hard they didn't schedule
this middle east trip immediately after
the nato summit
um you know there's a time difference to
deal with here there's a journey to deal
with here um how sharp is he going to be
how much will he be insulated by his
aides we simply don't know but the
underlying reality he's dealing with
here is that you know he has to swallow
his pride he has to forget those words
about saudi arabia being a pariah about
mbs paying the price for jamal khashoggi
he has to do business with the saudis he
needs those oil taps to be opened and
that means probably a public handshake
with the man that he's uh allowed the
cia to publicly accuse of murder
and paul just before i let you go um let
me get your thoughts on one thing which
is the difficulty of balancing this
conscience with
real polity the interests of nation
state as you mentioned them um you and i
as journalists you know we're on the
sidelines we're not making these
decisions and we can see where things
are going wrong in our view or with
hindsight perhaps but for those making
the decision i mean it is difficult
isn't it for a western leader like joe
biden who talks about human rights who
talks about freedom and he wants to
contain a country like china or russia
from preventing them to doing human
rights abuses elsewhere and then they
have to sidelight with someone like
saudi arabia
i'd see a bit of cognitive dissonance
seeing a lot of western voters and
western politicians
in
thinking you know
where that balance lies because i think
a lot of the time it does seem to be
more about national interest with human
rights as like bit of a cloak
yeah sure it's it's human rights uh
versus your own economic and security
interests
and it's a it's a problem for all
western democracies i noticed that liz
trusts uh one of the front-runners for
the job of prime minister of the united
kingdom
giving evidence to the foreign affairs
committee
a couple of weeks ago looked very very
conflicted she was quite artfully
questioned by the chairman
chris bryant and
um couldn't remember a single instance
or chose not to remember and talk about
a single instance in which she had
pressed a gulf country about human
rights and in the end she fell back on
the formula well these conversations are
private and it's better that they stay
that way exactly the same formula that
boris johnson used when he went to saudi
arabia in march after the war in ukraine
had started
asking begging the saudis to open the
oil taps and again he was asked what
about human rights he said we have to
keep these conversations private if they
are to be effective
um look there are risks in indulging
your conscience uh when you're when
you're a government and a country
the last time that human rights drove
american foreign policy you could say
was in the jimmy carter era when
revolted by
the shah of iran's secret police and the
repression that the shah was using to
stay in power
they backed the forces of change and
they got a regime changed to a
theocratic
dictatorship in the form of ayatollah
and all his successors and all the
problems of a nuclear-armed iran
possibly that we see today so this is a
high-risk game and for the moment at
least
[Music]
western leaders including president
biden have recognized the simple fact
that we do not choose the saudi leader
we have to deal with the saudi leader
that we've got
so liz trust said it is not a perfect
world
paul wood thank you so much for joining
spectator tv
and i'm now joined by mary kissel mary
was an advisor to
secretary of state mike pompeo under the
trump administration mary welcome to
spectator tv
it's great to be with you thanks for
having me
first of all i guess now that you're not
in the administration anymore can you
tell us would you how do you rate
president biden's uh middle east policy
so far
well to be honest i i don't think that
the president really prioritized foreign
policy i think his administration came
into office thinking much like the obama
administration before him that the
project was really about remaking
america and so
um he adopted many of the same policies
that his predecessor two presidents ago
adopted and tried to appease the world's
largest state sponsor of terrorism in
the region that's the islamic republic
of iran he shunned our friends in the
region saudi arabia
and the gulf nations and
as a result we we saw exactly the same
thing that we saw when we ran this
experiment a couple of years ago which
is that as we allowed tehran to
obtain more
cash they use that to spread their
malign influence around the region and i
think what you've seen is
unfortunately an increase in your
nuclear
capacity nuclear production capacity you
saw
an increased relationship with
other bad actors like communist china
and russia
they're now launching rockets into the
uae they've
launched attacks on northern iraq
and unfortunately uh this is not good
it's not uh good for the region it's
certainly not good for us national
interests and it's not good for anybody
who wants a sustainable peace in the
region
i mean something that paul and i were
discussing um and he writes about in his
piece is this conflict between
having a conscience basically
and the national interests of a country
like america you know mary you're
talking about iran and the need to
balance iran in the region but america
is also
leader of the free world it talks about
human rights it likes to protect human
rights and that is in fact one of the
reasons it has a problem with countries
like russia and china because of human
rights abuses so why does that matter
less when it comes to saudi arabia then
because this this is a country that is
pretty unsavory in many ways
well there are a couple of things there
that i think i'd like to correct first i
i'm not sure we are trying to
balance iran and every u.s
administration this administration may
be trying to do that but i think the
prior administration that i served in
tried to constrain
iran's terrorist activities and to forge
new diplomatic ties in the region and
you saw that come to fruition
in the abraham accords and secondly i
don't think anyone is downplaying um
human rights in saudi arabia
it's it's unfortunately it's a it's a
very difficult situation to deal with
because
it's a question if you go back to say
gene kirkpatrick right where she talked
about the different kinds
of authoritarian regimes there are those
authoritarian regimes that you can
talk to you can urge to reform that
share your strategic interests and you
kind of try to push along in the right
direction i think saudi falls in that
camp although you have to say it has an
absolutely horrific human rights record
um on the other hand you have
authoritarian regimes that
you can't talk to that have no interest
in reform and that want to kill you
and that's the islamic republic of iran
and what do you do in that situation
it's a it's a very difficult thing and i
i also think it's very different to be
kind of on the outside observing
and categoring categorizing these
countries as you know well this is a
quote-unquote good country and this is a
quote-unquote bad country
um that's simply not how foreign policy
works in the real world you're you know
dealing with a situation where you have
a power in the middle east in tehran
it wants to obtain nuclear weapons it is
vowed to destroy israel it has a global
by the way terrorist network they've
tried to kill saudi ambassador and here
in the united states not too long ago um
they have a hit out on my former boss
mike pompeo and our special envoy brian
hook they terrorize their own people
saudi arabia is not attacking its
neighbors uh in fact it's it's reached
out for peace now it doesn't excuse
uh their human rights they have made
some strides on women's rights but it's
nowhere near enough
and the cold reality of the world is
that you know saudi arabia may never
look like britain or the united states
iran
may not um what we want to do is we want
to create a situation where
we don't have conflict
where we secure
resources that the region and the world
needs um and that we try to constrain
and you know eliminate where we can
uh you know
activities by nations like iran that are
upsetting
that equilibrium that that that we want
and it's it's it's not an easy thing to
do i know i appreciate that and of
course as journalists sitting from the
outside you know you know much more
about what's happening inside the
administration i'm interested in picking
up one thing that you said there which
is about the ability to reform a country
like saudi arabia i think that will
eyebrow raise um
i think that will raise a lot of
eyebrows for people around
watching the show because it was only in
march before boris johnson visited saudi
arabia that they executed 81 people in a
single day
um we haven't really mentioned the
murder of jamal khashoggi and there are
reports as well that when pompeo and
trump were in administration even in
private meetings this kind of human
rights abuse weren't raised so what
efforts were made to reform this country
well
i don't know what reports you're
referring to but i i certainly know that
secretary pompeo
raised those concerns but you know it's
interesting when you talk about saudi
arabia iran's human rights abuses are
never mentioned and in fact they have
british hostages u.s hostages they
have basically torture chambers and evan
prison
and that's never mentioned um now uh you
know human rights is not a a contest
right for the worst offender
and it is indeed true
uh all of the statistics that you just
mentioned about saudi arabia as i said
it has a terrible record um at the same
time
you've seen
mbs curb the religious police
you've seen
enormous outreach to israel
you've seen
rights for women in courts in other
areas women in the workplace in saudi
arabia there's actually quite a lot
going on that i think doesn't receive an
awful lot of attention
and that's a shame
and again you know it's not a question
of uh
you know
one man and and the terrible thing that
happened to him it's
is this a nation that that wants peace
is it a nation that we can deal with
um or is this a nation that is spreading
terror around the world i think these
are two
very different places and also too we
shouldn't look at these places in
isolation and it's not a
u.s saudi relationship or a british
saudi relationship or a u.s iran
relationship these nations all talk to
each other they trade with each other
they cooperate with one another you have
to look at it through that lens too you
know who is saudi arabia trying to align
with it's trying to align with the gulf
nations and the free states of the west
who is iran trying to align with
communist china
uh russia
in fact vladimir putin is going there
just this week that he wants to buy
iranian drones
um you know these are two very different
things and i think it's a lot more
complex than simply asking you know what
happened in a single conversation to a
single man as awful as as the killing of
jamal khashoggi was fundamentally mary
for for yourself um in your foreign
policy access do you think that it's all
about alliances and the american
national interest um and wherever
possible
and wherever needed human rights would
be taking the back seat because of
national interest well again you know
what what protects ultimately human
rights
really at the end of the day
it's a democratic system
it's a rule of law it's institutions
it's uh the press right uh doing what
you do which is poking and prodding and
trying to figure out the truth and the
facts of what's
going on
so what is going to protect human rights
to the middle east more appeasing a
terrorist state
or trying to work with our partners in
the gulf and saudi and egypt in fact we
should give the bible administration
credit here um they are working to
advance
a formalized relationship between saudi
and israel i think that's absolutely
terrific
um they are also working on a missile
defense system
um with many nations in the middle east
uh that's a great step forward but you
also have to ask why is that happening
it's happening because these countries
have no confidence in this
administration
to side with them they see
the continued you know bowing and
scraping to tehran and that worries them
and so they're trying to figure out how
to create stability of their own it's a
very perilous time
and i think um you know i i wish uh the
president luck i hope he has a great
visit with mbs but i think it'll be a
tough meeting given how he's spoken of
him in the past and and also how he
withdrew his support for mbs's efforts
to
fight the iran-backed terrorists that
are firing rockets at civilian centers
in saudi arabia out of yemen
mary kissel thank you so much for
joining spectator tv
and finally is it inevitable that the
human race will spread across the stars
and if so will it be tech billionaires
like elon musk and jeff bezos who gets
us there
martin reece emeritus professor of
cosmology and astrophysics at cambridge
university shares his thoughts in this
week's issue he joins me now
martin reese thank you so much for
joining spectator tv to start with i
wondered if you could talk about the
pictures published by nasa this week
from the james webb telescope because
there's some amazing images coming out
of this um but to the layman it just
looks like you know pretty pictures what
are we actually seeing
here well they put out five different
pictures
and one of the most spectacular ones
indeed the first they put out
showed a tiny bit of sky
uh hugely magnified
as viewed through this telescope which
is a telescope in space with a mirror 21
feet across which is far more powerful
than any previous space telescope and
what it showed was a cluster of galaxies
quite a long way away
and
much further away huge numbers of little
smudges which are actually galaxies so
far away
that the light from them has taken
at least 90 percent of the time since
the big bang to get to us
and another interesting feature which
some people noticed was that uh some of
the uh distant galaxies uh looked
streaky they looked as though they were
slightly crescent shaped and the reason
for that is that the cluster of galaxies
along the line of sight exerts a
gravitational pull
on the light and bends the light and so
it's like a lens and so you're looking
at these very distant galaxies through a
sort of distorting lens which is caused
by the gravity of the cluster and they
purposely chose this particular patch of
sky to look at
because they knew it had a big cluster
with lots of galaxies in and also they
might see these extra effects so that's
just the first picture and by comparing
this with the
pictures taken with a hubble telescope
it's clear what a big factor improvement
this new telescope is in terms of
sensitivity to faint objects and also
sharpness of resolution and this was one
of the five pictures they
released yesterday um there was another
one which i thought was not spectacular
but is potentially interesting which was
uh something that told us about the
light coming from a planet around
another star
and everyone wants to know is the life
on other planets around other stars and
this is the first step towards a program
to try and answer that question
amazing and and though this has been
achieved by nasa it does seem like the
space agency has fallen in importance in
the public imagination
and in policy since let's say the height
of the space race um you write in your
piece for example in the 1960s that
nasa's budget was four percent of the
u.s federal budget and now it's less
than one percent why do you think there
has been this fall in importance
well the reason why there's been that
fall is that it was at this amazingly
high level of up to four percent of the
federal budget in the late 60s because
of the apollo program to beat the
russians to the moon
and this was not motivated by science or
anything practical it was just a
political uh rivalry and uh that of
course did lead to the famous landing of
neil armstrong on the moon in 1969
but having beaten the russians to the
moon there was no motive to pursue that
level expenditure i mean i'm old enough
to have remembered uh watching
that
picture of neil armstrong on the moon
and the later astronauts in the
following two years
and i and others thought at that time
that there might be footprints on mars
after another 10 or 20 years
but of course they haven't in fact after
the last people returned from the moon
in 1972
nobody no human has been
further
from earth than in low earth orbit
mainly in the space station and this is
really because
there's no practical need to send people
especially now that robots are getting
better
well maybe that's something that would
change as it looks like we're set to go
into a cold war with china in the next
few decades i mean china's got its
designs on the moon it's got its changa
missions um and
we already see a tech arms race between
china and the us on things to do with um
technology on earth so i wonder if that
space race do you think it will restart
well i think there may be a space race
um perhaps to uh
put
facilities on the moon but whether they
will involve humans
is not so clear to me and the chinese
might decide for reasons of uh
national pride to send people to the
moon or they might even decide to send
humans to mars because if they want to
assert their parity with the us it
wouldn't be enough to do what the
americans had done 50 years earlier so
they might decide to do these reasons
but um other than that
i don't think there's much case because
uh robots can now do the kind of things
which humans were needed for in the past
and of course if we're thinking about
mars
it's hugely much more expensive to send
humans and preserve them safely on a
200-day voyage than it is to send a
robot that's a hibernates on the way and
you need to bring back so my line in the
article and more generally is that
the case for humans
is just
as an adventure
exploration
rather like the people who
explored the southern hemisphere in the
17th century and the polar explorers etc
and
i think this should be left to private
enterprise
because
public
funding in the u.s and in europe has to
be very risk-averse if you're sending
civilians then you've got to ensure
they're safe the public won't accept a
high failure rate for instance the
shuttle
which send people up to the space
station was launched 135 times
and there were two failures
each of which killed the crew of seven
and those were traumatic events for the
americans
because they've been presented as safe
tourism as it were
but of course a less than two percent
failure rate
which is what that represents is
entirely acceptable to test pilots or um
adventurers and so
i think that we should leave this
venture of human uh space flights um to
uh mrs musk and bezos and other sponsors
um because they can
launch thrill seekers prepared to accept
high risks
and
they will go to mars perhaps some of
them one day tickets in fact
elon musk himself has said he wants to
die on mars but not an impact and he's
51 years old now so 40 years from now
good luck to him
absolutely well do you think that there
is a risk in letting private
entrepreneurs take the lead on this
insofar as
let's let's entertain this sci-fi
scenario where human race has colonized
other planets perhaps the moon um if we
let the first mover be private
individuals who are not elected who
represent the human race who are not
representative in any way themselves
because they're uber rich and have very
uh
idiosyncratic interests you know can
they be trusted to
make that first move there'll be lots of
resources that they could tap into give
them incredible power um isn't it better
in the hands of governments for that to
be happening
well my cynical answer will be can you
trust the americans
the uh i think a more realistic answer
is we're talking about just a few
pioneers and i think it's a dangerous
delusion which is held by elon musk in
particular that
there will be millions of people who
will want to go to mars to escape the
earth's problems that's a dangerous
illusion because although it's hard to
deal with climate change and all that
it's far harder
to terraform mars to make it as
habitable as the top of everest or the
ocean bed and so i don't ever see there
being mass
migration so i don't really uh worry
about
mars being heavily populated and those
sorts of issues arising i think we need
to worry about that for the moment on
the other hand i do say in the article
that i
um cheer these people on
because they will be away from the
regulators
who on earth are going quite rightly to
regulate the use of
cyborg and genetic technology
to modify human beings
uh
we don't want that to happen on the
earth we've got to regulate it but these
guys on mars they'll be away from the
clutches of the regulators moreover they
will have every incentive
to adapt themselves because they're very
poorly adapted to the gravity the
atmosphere and everything else on mars
and so my scenario
is that those crazy guys on mars
will pioneer what i'd call post-human
evolution they'll end up being a new
species because they will evolve um
at a rate what i call secular
intelligent design which is a much much
faster than dominion selection
and they'll be a different species and
they may at some stage become purely
electronic
in which case they might want to uh
leave a planet and go off into the blue
yonder and if they're near immortal then
they won't be deterred by a long
entertainer voyages so the far future
could be dominated by those entities and
one thing which as an astronomer i'm
probably more ever aware of than most
people is that
we are near the beginning than the end
of evolution it's taken about four
billion years to get from the first
embryonic life on earth to the biosphere
which we're apart
but the sun's
less than halfway through its life it's
got six billion more years to go before
it flows up and dies and the wider
cosmos may go on far longer so
in those
thousands of
certainly millions or billions of years
ahead then we can imagine changes which
would be at least as dramatic as the
ones that have happened through
darwinian evolution and so i think we
have no idea what
will happen on those vast time spans
but
i think we can say that this century is
rather special
which is the first century when
one species on one planet namely us here
on earth can actually uh uh trigger
these developments and have to
transition from flesh and blood to
electronic entities
do you think that in those billions of
years
something like climate change wouldn't
end the human race before then
in a sense that that would prompt us to
leave earth on mass
well i mean i hope we can deal with
climate change in the next hundred years
um but i think um even on earth
i don't think humans will survive
looking like humans for um
even one million years wow
and um and so uh life may have a longer
future on earth but the point is that we
are adapted by dominion selection
um to live on this earth and we cherish
it and be admired it's beautiful and we
don't want to change it too fast so i'd
be in favor of regulation
to limit the rate at which
our
earth and our physique and our
mentality can be changed by these new
technologies and hope we can preserve
the earth um in the face of the obvious
challenges which are already concerning
as you know because there are more of us
on the earth all more demanding of
ancient resources and all changing the
climate in a way that hasn't happened
in such a big way over any previous
century
martin i notice you you you say these
entities when you're talking about these
far in the distance um
descendants of us do you think that they
will still be human
um
well no i mean i i i think
well
i i think if we talk about the kind of
evolution it's going to happen away from
the earth
on mars or far beyond um they'll be as
different from us as we are from slime
mold
people
because the time for evolution
between uh
us and them is as long as the time is
taken for us to evolve from slime mold
and moreover duty evolutionary faster
because that will happen on a
technological time scale
which certainly is now when we say what
50 years or so uh whereas darwinian
evolution takes hundreds of thousands of
years
so we've no idea
what these entities would be in the far
future it's very exciting times and very
exciting to think about and martin just
finally before i let you go something
else that we must talk about is if human
if the human race is going to go into
the galaxy even more even beyond
chances of encountering other
intelligent life perhaps i mean in those
pictures from nasa uh this week we saw
that possibly there were some galaxies
that held water or life um
circumstances for life to develop so i
mean is that do you think an
inevitability that we will meet other
alien species well i'd like to say bell
is a harder subject in astronomy and so
we can't make confident predictions
about that but uh it's one of the most
important questions in science of course
um whether life was something which only
originated because of some rare fluke on
the earth or whether it's something was
would have started on many
environments like the earth and we now
know that there are many such
environments like the young earth on
planets orbiting other stars and uh one
reason why i'm excited about the james
webb telescope
is that i think uh it may well provide
the first clues uh to um whether there's
any sort of vegetation or biosphere on
any of those planets and that would at
least tell us that the origin of simple
life was something this wasn't a rare
fluke um as to the likelihood that that
would develop into something
intelligent which we could recognize as
such uh that of course is even more
uncertain but i think it's worth looking
and i think if we look at the
instruments that we'll have in the next
20 or 30 years even more powerful than
james webb
bigger telescopes on the ground which
european scientists are building for
instance
these will be able to clarify
whether there's any life and of course
if there are aliens out there
then
it's worth
a search and there are programs to look
for evidence for anything that's a
manifestly artificial
type of artifacts or to look for any
transmission that doesn't look natural
doesn't come to any kind of star
anything like that
and this is a search which has been
pursued with some private support in
particular um a uh russian-american
investor called yuri milner
is putting 10 million dollars a year for
10 years into a program and i chair his
advisory board and i'm very positive
about this which is simply going to uh
use existing radio telescopes
put some special instruments on them so
that they can be optimized to look for
transmissions that have unusual
properties which might be an indicator
of some sort of
intelligence or be relics of some
intelligence which existed in the past
martin rhys lord ruiz thank you so much
for joining spectator tv this really
puts the tory leadership contest into
context
right
that's it for this week
remember if you enjoy what we do here at
the spectator you can subscribe to the
magazine and to our online content join
today and you'll pay just one pound a
week for unlimited online and app access
in your first year
go to spectator dot co dot uk forward
slash tv offer
and don't forget you can subscribe for
free to the spectator's youtube channel
just click the subscribe button at the
bottom of this video and tap the bell
icon so you never miss an episode
thanks again for watching and do join us
next week
[Music]
you